so welcome to our continuing work on
understanding unsupervised learning uh
we're going through two kind of stalwart
algorithms which are pretty fun today
we're going to finish out PCA which is
this old standby we use it for
dimensionality reduction sometimes
visualization it's kind of a core
canonical unsupervised algorithm and
we'll talk about that today and I'll try
and refresh and be a little bit complete
there because I know we got cut off kind
of in the middle
if we have time uh well then we're going
to go through ICA we will have time for
ICA this is a fun problem this is this
cocktail problem you'll implement it
actually and it's a one of the ones
that's kind of a highlight every year
people talk about what are the favorite
homework problems they did and the
reason we're going to go through it is
it's a place where you make a kind of a
different assumption about how the noise
works it turns out if you make the kind
of traditional gaussian assumption here
which we've been making kind of through
class it breaks and so it's just nice to
to have an exposure like there's more
interesting things to do and it's also
kind of a fun problem if we finish those
two and there's some chance we do but if
we ask lots of questions that's actually
even better I'll show you some stuff
about weak supervision and I have some
slides prepared for that which are not
in the main deck but if we get to that
I'll I'll post the slides week
supervision the reason I would want to
talk to you about it is it's a more
modern technique it's behind some
products that you've actually used in
the last while and it's kind of one of
these things that looks like an em style
model but you can solve it in a very
direct way and since we're not having
another exam in the course you won't be
responsible for it it's a little bit
more advanced and so I can talk to you
about kind of how that works without
hopefully freaking you out Okay cool so
that's what I want to do today so let's
talk about PCA
all right so PCA if you recall we were
looking at these unstructured things I'm
just going to run through some of where
we were last time we're looking at the
structure and our structure is a
Subspace and it's a non-probabalistic
method so the two things are we wanted
some structure that we were looking for
underneath the covers remember GMM and
k-means were there's a clustering kind
of structure here we want to look for a
linear Subspace and we wanted the
non-probialistic version of that we
looked at this kind of contrived example
where we had pairs of Highway and City
miles per gallon and we were plotting
cars and we kind of intuitively would
guess like you know their hybrids up
here their SUVs down here and trucks
maybe and economy cars in the middle
and we wanted to understand what is a
notion of good miles per gallon that
took into account both Highway and City
and this was a way of motivating
effectively that what we wanted to do
was to kind of draw a line along the
direction that explained most of the
variance that was our intuition most of
the ways that they varied inside the
data set that was kind of that was
descriptive
so the way we did that is our first
mathematical thing is that we centered
the data recall we took the data we
subtracted off the mean and literally
last time I just copy pasted this data
and centered it at approximately the
center of of the data which is Mu and we
transformed it and the reason we
transformed it is we're using a linear
mapping that's what we want to do and
linear spaces go through the origin so
this just lets us use linear spaces and
have one fewer degree of Freedom when we
map them
special understanding although you
should think about it but it's really
critical if you run these methods if
they're Askew there will be no line
through the organ origin that
potentially goes through your data
once we did this I want to remind you of
some things that we're going to use from
linear algebra we have this idea around
we're going to prove formally what we
mean by the direction of maximal
variation and we kind of thought that
this line intuitively would be that
variation that is when we projected
things on the line either we had them
maximally spread out that means we
captured most of the variation that's
that's actually what that means or we
saw this dual thing in a second that the
residuals the amount of error in our
prediction on that line was small okay
and we'll talk about that again in a
second if you don't remember your linear
algebra remember that you can write once
you have an orthogonal basis you can
write any point in that space
as a um in that orthogonal basis namely
every one of the vectors that are
orthogonal U1 U2 in this example and
their distances along those lines we're
going to recall the math that does that
but that kind of gives you a new set of
coordinates for your data if your data
were a thousand dimensional it was given
to you in a thousand Dimensions you
could run PCA underneath it and find the
direction of maximal
variation and maybe it's second and
third components and then you could take
that thousand dimensional coordinates
which are a thousand numbers that you
were given and compress it down to three
and that's what we mean by
dimensionality reduction what are the
three best numbers if you like in some
sense that represent your data set okay
now just remember that fact that every
Point can be written in the basis and
really it's like the coordinates of like
how far do I go along U1 then I'm going
to go along the U2 Direction and get to
X1 this is Alpha One and this is Alpha
two
okay as we'll see below from last time
now the convention is that U1 and U2 are
unit vectors because we only care about
their direction we don't care about
their length or their magnitude and this
is just what you do there and so here U1
was kind of how good is the miles per
gallon
and mu2 was the difference between their
Highway and and City miles per gallon
roughly those aren't formal statements
that's just to give you an intuition of
what this basis looks like so you can
kind of have an intuitive feel of what
you're doing you want One Direction
which is the principal component of
variation and if you had a thousand
different uh uh points you would then
look at the other data sets and say what
other direction is the second principle
component third principle component and
if you remember your linear algebra that
is just how you write down a basis okay
that's all I'm describing but we have to
order those bases in some way we have to
figure out which components do we pick
first and among all of them and that's
what we're going to solve in PCA
all right okay so this is all just
saying X can be written in this form and
we may hear compressed from Dimension
two to Dimension One what that would
mean was we would probably just keep the
number alpha one that would just be we
would treat X as its projection onto
this line and just treat it as Alpha U1
okay
and that's what we mean by explains more
variation
okay so when we we're going to find
these directions today with some caveats
and we're going to think about thousands
of Dimensions to tens of Dimension and
this will be a dimensionality reduction
because we're going to only keep those
components so before I move on there's a
lot of linear algebra in there ask me
questions and I'm super happy to unpack
this because we're going to assume this
information so we try to that last time
going forward but I'm super happy to
answer questions and and derive
whatever's here that's unclear and if
you have the question almost certainly
somebody else does so please go ahead
and ask
please one of these
Alpha which is basically the
prohibitions are negative ah so they can
be negative right so for example in this
direction U1 is going this way if you
were to have a negative it would mean
that it was in the negative direction of
that these are signed so they they can
certainly be negative they're not
positive scalars here that's why we
worry about their squares for how much
of the residual is because they can be
positive or negative coefficients just
like you can have something that first
component is positive or negative and
the positive tells you to go this way
and then negative tells you to go that
way
[Music]
are based on
we don't know yet right so what we're
going to do is we're going to try and
find so all we know at this point that
we're trying to make sure that we get
there is that we can take an X and we
can write it down in a basis so X has
its original thing that it's given to us
and RN some large space we can write it
in new numbers alpha eyes for these uis
and this is a different basis for the
same underlying space and then what
we're going to try and do is say how do
we pick a good set of uis to represent
this and what I'm trying to hint at is
that we don't have to pick a complete
space we don't have to pick n orthogonal
basis vectors we're going to pick the
top K in some sense and that top K is we
hope captures the most variation and
we're going to make that precise in the
next couple of uh you know write-ups
awesome questions
please any others
wonderful point
okay so that's exactly what I mean we're
going to say how do we find those
directions okay and last time we talked
about this pre-processing we're going to
assume this for the rest of time I would
just say at some point reflect on this
we have to Center the data that's
because we're going to look through
lines that go through the origin we want
linear subspaces so that makes sense
that we would want our data to kind of
have a chance for these lines to explain
the maximal variation that's why we
Center that's important we will also
rescale the components so that they have
about the same amount of space so
imagine if one of your components was
miles per gallon and another one was
feet per gallon the feet per gallon
because it was you know 5 000 times the
numbers were five thousand times larger
they would be at vastly different scales
right and if you go through the
calculations below because you're taking
squares and doing things because they're
at different scales that kind of makes
them you know unreasonably important
right so one of the things that you'll
typically do is then scale by the
variance in each Direction and then
allow them to kind of all be spread kind
of about a gaussian because they're
centered component wise and then divided
by that variance
that's just the other piece of
pre-processing that that goes on okay
all right
so now we've done that
we've we've done those pieces we need a
couple of bits of mathematics just you
know to remind yourself of what it means
to find these kind of components so here
we have two components U1 and U2 and
their unit vectors as we talked about
before
and they're orthogonal that means their
dot product is equal to zero they're
perpendicular to one another okay
now what we want to find one of the
things that we have to find are kind of
a subroutine intellectually of what we
have to do is to find the coordinate
Alpha One on this line it makes sense
that it's the closest point
actually on this line to X
right that would be the point that we
would project it on that's what
projection means actually it's the
closest point on the line in this sense
okay and euclidean geometry so what does
this line This is the set of all T times
U1 so that's any scalar positive or
negative as pointed out that scales this
entire line and so basically our
optimization problem to find this
component Alpha One Is to find the T
that gets me to this closest point now
geometrically it will hopefully be
intuitive that that should be
perpendicular right to this line this
line here will be perpendicular and the
reason is is the rest will be explained
by U2
okay all right so let's find out how we
find the closest point to the plane and
I'm going to write it out now so how do
we do that
just remind ourselves so how do we do
that so alpha 1 is going to be equal to
the ardman this is just rewriting what I
said overall Alpha such that we have
here x minus Alpha U1 square the square
just makes our life a little bit easier
kind of mathematically squares Norms of
squares of norms are just easier to work
with doesn't really make any difference
in the underlying piece but this is just
saying among all the oops among all the
alphas let me get that among all the
alphas which are running up and down
this line I want the one that has the
closest distance to X that's what I'm
calling the projection
okay so what does that equal
well this is the same as doing the ARG
man let me write it on the next line
actually
the ardman
and I'm just going to expand this Norm
out
so it's x squared
plus Alpha Square
U1 Square minus 2 Alpha
x dot U1 okay and this is I'm just
writing the dot product in a notation
hopefully not too confusing this is just
a DOT product okay just to make it clear
without having little tiny dots to look
at
all right so a couple things right away
this term
is one because it's a unit Vector it's a
unit vector
and this term is irrelevant for Alpha
Alpha's value here doesn't change the
value of x x is given
so this is equivalent for us when we
take the derivative oops
we take the derivative with respect to
Alpha of this expression
this expression looks like to us
Alpha Square minus 2 Alpha
X U1
okay and when we take the derivative
with respect to Alpha of this thing it's
the derivative with respect to Alpha of
this expression that equals 2 times
Alpha which is from the first one minus
X U1
okay
now to set this equal to zero this is
equal to zero this implies Alpha equals
x dotted and E1
comma
that's all that's saying
all right so this is just saying
something you may have forgotten from
linear algebra or you're now remembering
which is that the dot product of a unit
Vector is actually a projection
all right
so far so good
okay
now
one piece here is that we can generalize
to higher dimensions
to more components
and it's worth actually thinking about
what this looks like right so the point
is when we when we write this down
we're going to have here
U1 to UK for some value of K this is
just for an exercise for arbitrary value
of K element of Rd
some X that's also living in Rd
and then here
we're going to calculate coordinates
alpha 1 to Alpha D such that x minus sum
k equals 1 to D
uh Alpha k u k is smallest
clear enough this is finding the closest
point in the Subspace instead of a line
we're finding the closest point in the
Subspace
hopefully clear and you remember this if
not please ask a question super easy to
explain
all right
so by the same basic reasoning you
compute the derivative you unpack it you
have to use the fact that the uiks are
orthogonal why when you expand the
squares right you're going to get
products of UK dot into UJ
and those will cancel out and so you'll
basically have just a bunch of
Expressions that are that are present in
which Alpha K is going to be
x minus UK and this is only because
they're orthogonal only because
orthogonal
UK or orthogonal
okay
and you can do that derivative very very
quickly
okay now this quantity here
is important
that's a terrible highlight let's use
this one
this thing here is called the residual
right
all right
this is the residual
and what we care about when we're going
to do PCA is we either want to we either
want to find that we want to find a set
of points a set of directions such that
when we do this projection onto them the
sum of all the residuals is minimized
okay so this this tells us the residual
for a given point and a given basis
and now I have an optimization problem
right and I'll write it out formally in
a second but intuitively you can think
about what's going to happen is I'm
going to pick
you know K of these U's that are going
to be orthogonal there are many of them
that I could pick many orthogonal uh
bases that I could pick I pick one of
them then I project all of my data onto
that set
I measure how well I did by either how
much I captured in the data set or by
how much was missing which is the
residual and this is the residual
I then have that per point so I sum up
over all of those and this gives me a
score of how good that basis was and
among all the bases I want to pick the
one
that minimizes the residual or maximizes
the projected Subspace
so let me write some of that down and
then you ask questions if you like
so we can find PCA by two things by the
way this is not this is a this seems
like trivial uh potentially
um
that the maximizing the projected space
or variance and the minimizing distance
are the same it's actually not true in
general for for other geometry so it's
actually quite a nice thing about
euclidean space that doesn't matter to
you but just kind of a comment
it's residual
all right so let's do this one this is
the one we're going to do in class
maximize the projected space
so let's do it for one vector so now we
want to pick among all the possible U's
what's the debt what's the version uh
what's the particular setting of you
that explains the most about our data
and so what that's going to be from our
our previous discussion is this
Max U over Rd
subject to U equals one this two Norm is
equal to one
over an average over all the points
although of course such a constant
doesn't really matter because we're
maximizing but it's nice to have the
right scale
U dot x i Square
okay
so what we're saying here we pick a
direction and this direction we want to
get the largest dot product right how
much this is the project this is X1
projected into this this is the alphas
the sum of those Alpha squared I's we
want to be as big as possible so we want
to pick the direction among all the
directions so imagine in two direct and
2D you're just kind of spinning around
and you're you're judging how great the
Subspace is by maximizing how much is
present
okay we need a couple facts to solve
this hopefully the the point is clear
we need some facts to solve this
okay
so first fact we need we need to recall
is let a
be a symmetric
and square Matrix
kind of makes sense
okay then
it's a normal Matrix and in particular
it can be written like this
you Lambda U transpose
where u t equals I the basis is
orthogonal
and Lambda is diagonal
okay not all matrices are diagonal
not all matrices are orthogonally
diagonal
but if it's symmetric and square
it's called normal
then it has this and Lambda has has a
nice interpretation Lambda I I the since
it's a diagonal matrix
equals Lambda I and we call these the
eigenvalues Lambda 1
and they're real
okay by convention so we order them this
way just because it's nice to talk about
them is Lambda 1 being the big one
Lambda n being the small one
okay now if you don't remember your
linear algebra maybe this doesn't seem
mysterious to you but if you think about
the like underlying model like there's
no reason in general these things should
even be real value they could be complex
valued in general but if they're
symmetric and it's nice then this
happens they're real and they can order
them which is really nice okay so we're
going to use that fact and if that's
confusing to you to remember what
happens when you diagnose over the
complex plane don't worry about it at
all just take this as a fact
okay
all right so
these characters here as I mentioned
these are the eigenvalues
all right so recall
if x equals
sum k equals 1 to n
Alpha k u k
where
U1 u n equals U
we can write the following thing we can
write alpha x ax sorry is equal to U
Lambda U transpose X
this is equal to U Lambda sum k equals 1
to n
Alpha k e k oh sorry
e k sorry let me write it like this
uh I don't want to write it that way
yeah okay perfect yeah
Alpha k e k what's going on here U
transpose U is exactly the identity so
all that's going on here is
since it's what when I dot product UK
into one of these which one survives
exactly UK right if it's different if
it's UJ that's different then they're
going to contribute zero so this becomes
Alpha K in the standard basis
this is a standard basis that's
confusing ask a question
what's going on here again X is written
in this form what happens when I
multiply U transpose by X it multiplies
it by each of the uis only one of them
survives
for the kth term only the case one
survives because otherwise they would be
zero and so I get this
then when I multiply it by the diagonal
matrix I get U times sum
k equals 1 to n
Lambda K Alpha k e k
and then I get back to
sum k equals 1 to n i multiply by U
again I get Lambda K Alpha k u k because
again when I multiply e k
the basis Vector right this is the
vector where it only has a one in the
kth position by U it selects out UK and
I get back and so what this means is
this is a long-winded way of saying if I
multiply a in this basis all it does is
act by multiplying by the eigenvectors
this is an eigen decomposition if you
remember it that's all that's going on
right
please
[Music]
nice property that we can get all of
these because once we have the use then
you can you know user that is
yeah yeah so I think the the we haven't
gotten back to PCA yet we need one more
fact hold on just one minute and we'll
come back to that we're just recalling
like facts from your linear algebra
class yeah
but there's a great point you should be
thinking exactly that right so let me
just point out one fact here
which is that if I take the max over all
the unit vectors of X transpose X
a
it can also be written and this is the
formula we've been we've been kind of
hinting at
as Alpha Square sum k equals 1 to n
Alpha K Square
Lambda k
okay
so now if you think about this how do
you find the principal eigenvalue
how do you find the largest way to
express this well since we only get to
spend oops since we only get to spend
our Alpha squared along the components
and we only have a one unit to spend
what maximizes this expression
well
we want to put as much value go ahead
because when we multiply here by X
Alpha times x is going to be equal to
this expression
and then when we dot X in again we get
the alpha squares because they pair up
to one another yeah apologies if I went
too fast
great question so we have the alpha
squares times the Lambda case now the
Lambda case because they're let's
imagine they're you know one to ten
where would you put all your mass if you
wanted to maximize this well on the
largest one right
so how do you maximize the amount of
mass you put on the largest one you put
in our in our notation
Alpha One equals one
because the rest are all then equal to
zero this is going to be the largest one
and that's the principal eigenvector
imagine they're strictly different
does that make sense
please
for many years
yeah we're here
um
yeah yeah so how does it then suddenly
become
this one is just the fact that it's
diagonal so e k times a diagonal is just
the case eigen unit Vector times that
value and so that pulls it out pulls out
Lambda K which is on the diagonal
yeah and then when you have it when you
have a unit Vector multiplied by a
matrix it just selects out that column
okay but is this clear if I want to
maximize this I set Alpha One equal one
right because we know Lambda 1. now what
if Alpha One what if Lambda 1 equals
Lambda 2.
that is there two eigenvalues that are
hot that are that are that are present
Lambda 1 equals Lambda 2.
then it turns out there's an entire
Subspace of solutions
right I could pick any alpha 1 and Alpha
2 such that the squ that they're Square
sum to one anywhere on that Circle
and if Lambda one equal Lambda 2 equal
Lambda 3 now I can pick anywhere in a
Subspace of size three
that's going to be important when we
think about how well-defined PCA is
because it's only well defined what the
principal component of variation is if
Lambda 1 is strictly bigger than Lambda
2. right if there's no Gap then you can
it doesn't the coordinates aren't well
defined anymore I can pick anything I
just described does that make sense
all right please
so alpha 1 is equal to one and the
reason is so if this constraint this
Norm constraint means that I have to
pick among all the alpha such that
they're Square sum to one
so if among all the ones that square sum
to one which one's going to give me the
biggest value intuitively I want to put
all my mass on Lambda 1 because Lambda 1
is the biggest value right
and so that setting I would set alpha 1
equal to 1 and all the alpha k equal to
0 for K greater than one that would be
the value that I would pick there
because that just that one's guaranteed
it you know I can't really do better
than that if I slide off even an Epsilon
amount of mass well then it's going to a
smaller eigenvalue and because I I lost
that mass I would get you know Epsilon
Square times that
okay you can also just compute the
derivative using lagrangian if the
intuitive thing doesn't make sense
which we did two lectures ago
cool all right so let's go back to PCA
and say exactly where do we get this
this UI the thing I wanted to point out
that is here I'm going to come back to
this point about what happens with
Lambda 1 and Lambda 2 if you missed it
don't worry
I just care that
you're aware that what we're doing in
the maximization now back to PCA
okay so recall I'll just go up here
sorry I'll copy because I'm extremely
lazy where is our PCA
where did we do this oh here
I just want to like make sure you
realize I'm not like doing something
strange and changing the
expression this is what we wanted to
deal with
well this expression here we can rewrite
and we can rewrite it as x i
transpose
U transpose
oh sorry X transpose U
transpose
x i
sum I goes from 1 to n one to n okay let
me drag that and give myself a little
bit more space here so it's not crowding
you too much okay so this is equal these
two expressions are equal I'm just
expanding out the square
but this is pretty nice because now I
can pull out you
oh sorry I wrote it backwards I don't
want to do this let me write it the
other way it'll just make my life easier
in the next move you too I'm so sorry
about that
expose transpose you okay
sorry that was that was foolish it's
true but foolish
okay so now I can pull out the use
because they're on the outside this is U
transpose sum I equals 1 to n
x i
X I transpose U
okay why is that because this is linear
so I can pull this out of the sum
and all of these things are are paired
up
this thing here
is this is a quantity that you may
remember previously
this is the covariance of your data
why is it the covariance because you
subtracted off the mean this is the
sample covariance and so here I can push
the one by n inside let me do that too
1 by n and then it's really the sample
covariance
okay this thing here
so then what will you be
if I want to maximize this U
well it will be the Principal eigenvalue
right this is an eigenvalue problem just
as we went up here it's now of this form
we can verify is it symmetric
yeah it's a symmetric it's a sum of
these are each are a sum of symmetric
matrices so the covariance is symmetric
it is actually really a covariance
matrix
it also happens to be positive
semi-definite that means all the lambdas
are non-negative so that's good news
we didn't need that but that's nice to
have
and now when we look at the U's as we go
through there we have to pick a
direction which direction do we pick
well we're going to pick the direction
that corresponds to Alpha One which is
U1 right which is the basis when we do
the decomposition here it's the
principal eigenvector of this thing
so the best you to pick is the principal
eigenvector of the covariance
right
some of you are nodding some of you look
like I said something horrible so please
both ask questions
this is a covariance we're going to sub
this covariance Matrix into the a
awesome
what happens if we want two components
what do you think we pick
anyone
the first two that correspond to the
largest two eigenvectors three the
largest three
if the first two are equal
and you want One Direction Lambda one
equals Lambda 2. now you got a problem
because you have two potential
representations for it
but you can still pick a component of
principal variation and that's the way
that PCA is potentially undefined
okay
all right
cool that's all it is so how do we
represent data with this just to make
sure it's clear
well we map x i
I
some let's say we picked D dimensions
x i minus u j u j
namely this is its coordinates in the
top K eigenvalues that we picked on
average this captures the most variance
in our data and we just keep this is a
scalar this is you know what we were
calling Alpha J earlier
we just keep these k scalars
okay so this map what it does it takes
in a thousand Dimensions let's say I
started with a thousand dimensions
then it's going to pick five
which five well they're going to be a
blend of those they're not going to be
any individual Dimension they're going
to be this these eigenvectors of the
underlying covariance
they capture the most the reason we like
them is they capture the most of our
data they throw away the least amount of
our data which is the other residual
interpretation and this gives us a map
that goes from you know R let's call it
Big D down to R Little D okay
and that's in what sense this is a
dimensionality reduction and we can use
that for example to take our data and
take it from 100 dimensions and project
it onto two and visualize it draw it on
a map
um yeah awesome peace
[Music]
yeah great question so you want to know
how do you pick K or D here Little D
so let's hear in contrast for the last
three
uh lectures I've been telling you I have
no idea how to pick K here I at least
have an idea oh go ahead oh I'm just
confused
I think I confuse you with something so
let me make sure this let me just call
this K just for now to make this K is
less than what you're thinking of as D
how about that
that's a great point so it's decomposed
into D dimensional vectors but it only
now takes K coordinates to represent it
so again going back to the
two-dimensional picture we have a
two-dimensional picture but we projected
everything onto the line and so now we
can represent things by just its
distance on the line the alpha one so
we've taken two scalars which were like
it's X and Y coordinates and reduce it
to just one which is the Alpha One
does that sound make sense awesome
all right so let's see how we pick K
here
how do we pick k
and this won't be super satisfying but
you know whatever be fine
okay
so this actually does have some have
some kind of trick so what does this
actually mean so this is this is
basically looking at the trace of a
which is equal to this sum on the bottom
Lambda I
okay so if you know if you remember your
linear algebra but basically what it's
saying is what I want to know is how
much of the space am I explaining so
imagine I have 100 dimensions
intuitively if I get the top 10 of them
the worst case is that they explain
point one of my space meaning that my
sum of those eigenvalues are about 0.1
and I'm throwing away roughly 90 of my
data it's not what it means but just
kind of think intuitively what this is
saying is that traditionally people will
pick K here so that they explain a lot
of their data and so if your data does
your data like you know as a Rough Guide
if I pick 10 components of your data and
do PCA on it do I capture 90 95 then
that means that was a good selection and
you can now compare K's based on how
their eigenvalues are ordered if it goes
down to 10 to the minus 10
right your fifth component is 10 to the
minus 10 you don't need it pick the
fourth instead just pick bases of four
so now it gives you a way to actually
start to compare them and you can get
error guarantees you may worry Computing
these eigenvalues is super expensive
because you have to compute like an SVD
on some Mega Matrix but you don't have
to and the reason is this is a trace and
if you remember your Trace equalities
you can just sum the values on the
diagonal to get the trace which is the
sum of the eigenvalues please
and that was like too large
um and say that this quotient came out
to be like very very high like 0.999
right would you saying that you're
overfitting yeah it's exactly right it's
like it's a finger overfitting you don't
need to do it and so it's kind of like
if you're if you're keeping those extra
pieces of information like intuitively
you don't you want the smallest K that
you have most of your data so you can
tack on more but it's kind of like
what's the additional value to do it
traditionally you'll use K as I said PCA
kind of is a visualization technique or
like to get some rough sense of the data
and so you try not to have K higher than
two or three and it just provides a
sanity check like if you run PCA and the
first two components of your uh you know
your eigenvalues account for almost
nothing in your data then it's not
really clear what conclusions you can
draw right
the other place where it can cause you
pain is the thing that I keep
illustrating which is that if Lambda 1
and Lambda 2 are equal to each other
which on real data is actually very
unlikely but numerical issues could make
them kind of come together then the
coordinates could be pretty fragile
right so I run PCA once and I get you
know one comma two comma three as my you
know sorry Alpha One Alpha 2 Alpha three
but then I run it the next time and
because I chopped it three and the first
four were equal some new coefficient
comes in right so really like those are
the instabilities that you worry about
the most if like your lambdas are a
bunch of lambdas are really really close
to each other then your coordinates
aren't really preserved and anything
inside the Subspace goes so that's the
other problem with PCA it really only
makes sense when the spectrum is is
separated and people don't usually check
that and as a result they uh lead to
erroneous conclusions so you tack on too
many you get there and then also you can
have these issues about
um you know non-fidelity in the
representation those are the two main
ones you got it perfectly
okay awesome
any other questions about PCA now you
know it you love it so much
all right great
all right let's talk about ICA
all right so ICA sounds very similar to
PCA we only change one letter but it has
nothing to do with it one has nothing to
do with the other so that's refreshing
uh but they have
um something about them that I really
like
so
all right so first I'm going to tell you
the high level story of ICA which is
this cocktail party story
high level story then some key facts
these key facts are useful because you
will run into them in your homework and
I just want to highlight them
and then we'll talk about the model and
the model will be the least interesting
part
so here's how it works here's the high
level story
we have people and by the way I think
their homework is the world's most
boring cocktail party I think they like
count numbers to 10 or something
so it's not like you're going to hear
some salacious gossip you're just going
to hear people counting to ten some TA
from like five years ago all right so
anyway
so you have people here are two people
they're happy
those are people one and two we have
microphones over here mic one
mic two
okay now here's our problem when the
people speak they don't speak directly
into one microphone they're just ambient
microphones and so what happens when
this person you know compresses the
sound waves
is that boom it hits microphone one but
also it hits microphone too
similarly when person two speaks
they speak in some way
that same this is supposed to be the
same wave by the way so like the wave
didn't change based on them but it just
took longer to get to the microphone
we're not going to worry about length
too much but the point is what
microphone one and microphone two uh C
is a mixture of the sounds they don't
just hear one person they hear two
speakers simultaneously superimposed on
one another and the goal is to take what
we record at these microphones and
recover kind of the time series of what
they actually said and since if we had
the wave that's just the air we could
play it through a speaker and we would
actually hear what person one and person
two said
and you'll be able to do this and it
works which is kind of wild now I do
want to emphasize having built things
that look sort of like this this is a
naive way to look at the problem in the
sense of like what you would build if
you were doing this in industry but so
what it gets you the core principles and
you can look there's whole things about
speaker identification and in fact like
there are certain companies that when
they ship their products they brag about
how they can identify different speakers
in the home so like as weird as this is
like people ship products based on their
ability to do this okay
all right please ask questions if the
setup doesn't
um make sense
two we have data X
and we'll see it for some time we're not
going to assume things or make this
simple the people aren't moving around
in the room uh they're not changing just
just to make our lives a little easier
okay so we need to look at what does the
actual data look like
all right so as I mentioned
oops
speaker one is going to be kind of this
time series
that looks like this
okay now we don't actually see the whole
continuous thing
what we see is we see speaker one
we don't even see this by the way this
is what kind of we get samples at
various regular intervals that's the way
we conceptualize the problem this is
like how audio processing works right
um
two at a time one
so on let me just draw this and I'll
talk
and these should be evenly spaced if I
could draw properly and had enough
patience
okay time one the point is is what you
see
is that you just get these measures of
intensity so s t j is
speaker
J intensity at time t
okay now we want to recover this if we
had this we were in good shape right if
you think about how you actually record
audio you know kind of high-end audio is
usually recorded around 44 kilohertz
right give or take you can probably
understand people much lower kilohertz I
don't know exactly where it breaks down
um but my point is is like this is
actually how digital recording works
right you sample at a bunch of points
you get the intensities and then you
play it back through a speaker
okay
all right and then there's speaker two
which I'll also draw oops
and then just so it's clear like we
sample them at a bunch of points too
maybe speaker two more loquacious I
don't know
S one two
oops those look terrible I don't know
why I'm gonna fix this but I am
and these are sampled at the same time
point so my drawing doesn't do is
imperfect in many many ways
uh two two s
t two so on blah blah blah okay and
these are going to be sampled at the
same time points just to make our lives
easier okay
all right so now we don't get to see
this as I mentioned
we don't see
S1 and s2's Time series
right we get to see the microphones
only
XT
1 and xt2 which are sampled at the
microphones
okay
so far so good
so we need a model of how we're going to
do this and of course kind of our model
from what we described above is going to
look something like this
the time that what we observe at
microphone J at time t
is a mixture
of something from speaker one
and something from speaker two
okay so microphone J just to make sure
it's clear here Mike J sees a mixture
and we're going to assume this mixture
is fixed
right just for the moment right if
they're moving around the room
that's not true any longer but we're
going to assume it's fixed for the
moment
okay so I can write this compactly as
X of T equals a of s of t
all right now what do we know here
this we observe
this is the data
both of these are latent
we don't know the mixture
we don't know the speaker intensities
okay for the moment I'm going to assume
that the number of speakers and the
number of microphones are the same
you can imagine because there's a matrix
here that you know if I have only one
microphone this is going to be
substantially harder actually impossible
to to do the Reconstruction but I'm
going to take advantage of the fact that
I have different mixtures at these
microphones okay so assume I have number
of microphones the same as the number of
speakers
okay so is the setup the high level
story and setup clear intuitively what
should happen
right let me write some math
sure
it is a is actually the mixture so a
right here this model says that what we
see at time T it's from at microphone J
is some fixed mixture of what speaker
once at a time T and speaker two set at
time T we're not modeling any delay or
anything like that so they make their
the sound they go ah and then it hits
the microphone and then the you know the
mixture of person one and person twos uh
pressure hits the microphone at the same
time
they don't they don't actually matter
the physical units don't matter in any
way but you can think about them as any
unit of pressure that you want okay
is a is unitless a is just a pure
mixture you can multiply and add things
because the s's are the same type
cool all right so let's make this a
little bit more mathematically precise
so we're given
X1
X
n element of r d
and D is the number of mics and speakers
what we have to do
is find
S1
to SN that's also amount of Rd okay so
I'm preferring to have the notation over
time
we also are going to find although we
really don't need it for the model this
a
that is d by D
okay such that
X of T equals
a s of T now if we estimated a right
there's a pretty easy way to find what
we wanted if we knew a someone gave it
to us this problem is Trivial just take
the X's multiply by a inverse and you
have yourself the S's
right
now
the terminology is we call a the mixing
Matrix for the reasons I just outline
a the mixing Matrix and W equals a
inverse which will use the unmixing
Matrix so why would I introduce and
bother you with this it turns out that W
is actually the right way to write a lot
of the guarantees and you'll see why in
a second
okay so we're going to write this as
right w
is equal to W1 transpose to w d
transpose and I'm just doing this so
that I can write the following so that
this is just one way of writing the
inverse so that sjt equals
W J times x t nothing happened here I'm
just giving you notation of how I think
about the mixing and then this inverse
is going to be important the inverse is
kind of obviously important because we
want it if we had the a we would
multiply by its inverse on both sides
and that would tell us the speaker that
we were after right so w is what we need
to multiply by
okay now the things that I actually find
interesting about this model
so some caveats we talked about some of
these
a does not vary with time
we're assuming that
time if it did we have to use something
more complicated
so we're not going to do that
two this is more interesting to me there
is inherent ambiguity in this model
I like when there's inherent ambiguity
when you can't tell two things apart
because it forces you to understand what
the model is doing
so one thing we can't determine speaker
one versus speaker two
we have no idea who speaker one and
who's speaker two in real life so it can
we can only determine up to kind of how
we permute their Time series
okay so speaker idea is opaque to us
maybe one time we were on the algorithm
are indistinguishable we don't know the
labels
okay of course we can tell that there's
one person who's you know saying numbers
in English and one who's saying numbers
in French we just can't tell who's doing
what in this model
the other thing which is maybe a little
bit more subtle is we can't determine
absolute intensity and I'll just write
the equation
and it's because we're multiplying two
things together so notice that if I take
any constant multiply it times a and
then take that same constant and
multiply it times s
this is still equal to a of s of t
so we can possibly only know that the
person we can't tell how loud S1 and S2
are we can tell relatively how loud they
are but the mixing Matrix we could
multiply by a constant and it wouldn't
you know wouldn't change anything right
it was the scaling would go through and
because we're multiplying them in our
framework
we can't determine this either
now that has a surprising surprising
thing
and this is why kind of I like to teach
it intellectually oops surprising
the speakers cannot be drawn from a
gaussian distribution we're going to
have to make some statistical assumption
but they cannot be gaussian
why suppose they were
x i
would then be
a normal drawn with some mean from aat
but then as we saw before
if u t u equals I
then a u
generates the same data
what does that mean
s that any rotation of a generates the
same data multiplied by U
and the reason it happens is because the
data here are rotationally invariant
because they're Co their their
covariance Matrix is a times a transpose
and that is not sensitive enough to tell
about all these rotations the same
reason we love gaussians because they
were rotationally invariant means that
that symmetry
we can't recover anything in this
problem
and so that at that point you may think
gosh there's no way we're going to be
able to do this we have all these
symmetries around the speaker and we can
rotate the X the the intensities in any
way we want what are we going to be able
to do and it turns out you can recover
something here and weirdly enough as
long as the uh distribution roughly
speaking is not gaussian and is not
rotationally invariant you can recover
it and that's kind of remarkable and
it's worth thinking about
okay now the algorithm is going to be so
trivial
the algorithm is just going to be
gradient descent and mle
we're just going to set up a likelihood
function and run everything that we've
been running so far okay that's it
all right now we need one trick
one half second you know two minute
detour because this this causes problems
every time people look at this
it's just one little detour about how
random variables behave
under linear transformations
under
linear transform
all right
all right and this is just the reason
I'm doing this is It's a key confusion
if you remember your I don't know I'm
not going to say what you should
remember some calculus thing just basic
you know change of variable formulas for
integrals this will make sense but we
can draw it in pictures and you don't
need to know that at all so here we go
so just imagine I have something that's
uniform on zero one
okay and now I have a new variable U
which is equal to 2 times s
what is the PDF
of U in terms of s
now we're tempted
to write
P of U
X over 2 equals P of s of x
now
let's take a look at the PDFs
so here's the PDF of U
it goes from 0 to 1 and what's its
height
well we integrate over the entire thing
it's one
right
this is our PDF
of you
sorry of s sorry PDF of s
this is the uniform
now
for you what happens we go from zero
here's one to two we know we have
support from zero to two because it's a
uniform distribution right you grab a
point here you multiply it by two and
it's going to sit somewhere in here oops
go away
right it's going to sit somewhere in
here
but what is its height
it's got to be one half
so this relationship is clear
so PS of X is going to be equal to 1 if
x element of 0 1
it's 0 otherwise
pu of of x
is going to be equal to PS of X over 2
times one-half
okay
and that's just the normalizing constant
and so this key issue here is this
normalizing constant
yep
normalizing constant that's it
so when we do this in higher dimensions
we have p u of x
and we want to map by some linear a
oops
so that is like a u for example right
what happens right
right oh sorry a s that's the way we're
writing this because I want to keep the
notation a s equals U
what happens in higher dimensions
well we still have p u of X is equal to
PS of a inverse X but we need a
normalizing constant here
and how does it take if you imagine I'm
taking a box
and I multiply it by a a matrix a
what how does the volume change
that's the determinant
that's all a determinant does takes a
box and the volume of it is going to be
exactly proportional to the assigned the
absolute value of the tournament this
determinant is signed because it's a
oriented measure
but that's what you get okay
you can convince yourself in two
Dimensions pretty easily in higher
Dimensions it actually requires a little
bit of work potentially to do it and
this you probably learned as your change
of integrals form change of volume
integrals formula
uh at some point
times the determinant of w okay
okay now the thing that I used here was
the fact that one over the determinant
of a is equal to the determinant of a
inverse
when I did that
okay so the point is when you do change
of variables you have to take this
determinant into account you probably
did this with a Jacobian at some point
in your life
and if you didn't don't worry about it
it's not that big a deal it just says if
I take a box and I and I map it by a
linear transformation what's the volume
of the Box going back to this uniform
case and then if you care about how you
would probably prove this you just think
about like integrals you break out into
tiny little boxes
that's it
whatever space you're integrating so
this we did it for one box but you can
do it for many
okay so we're going to use this formula
for the rest of our time please
okay so yeah so the the idea here is
that we have a probability distribution
in one space now I want to probability
distribution in my new space so I have
from zero to two so I'm going to take
the X and I'm going to divide it by 2
and whatever the height is over there
I'm going to get it so if the height is
one I get it the height is zero then
that should be right as well but when I
do that the problem is is the
probability distribution I had I'm using
that value will be one right when I do
that and I need to just multiply by some
constant so I'm thinking here about the
PDF for that random variable yeah so so
basically you can ask you as a product
it's a random variable and so a random
variable is nothing more than like some
function on the it's just an integral
yeah awesome question
all right so once we have this fact this
problem is super easy
ICA is mle
why is that
P of s equals sum J equals 1 to D
s of SJ okay this is where we use the
sources are independent
we have to assume this in the model
and they have some distribution that's
not gaussian
but not gaussian
this equals so then P of X is now equal
to
the probability J goes from 1 to D
of
p s w times x times
the determinant of w
but now this is something that we can
compute
this is written in terms of X and our
Matrix a
and we can just do gradient descent on
it
okay
so how does that work here's the key
technical bit
right we're going to set
PS of x
proportional to G Prime X
4 G of x equal to 1 plus e to the minus
X inverse there's nothing really magical
about this function except for it's not
rotationally invariant
and then we can solve
the likelihood of w is sum from time
goes from 1 to n
um J goes from 1 to D
log
G Plus
W J
x t
plus log
determinant of w
okay so maybe this looks pretty
intimidating but what happened here
this G is just some likelihood function
I don't actually care what it is that's
the thing that's weird that's the thing
I want you to confront it's not that
it's like some specially chosen function
when we would pick the gaussians we were
picking it because of computational and
kind of other reasons oh it only had two
moments and we could compute everything
we wanted this is basically saying
honestly I can pick almost any G I want
any likelihood function I want on the
speakers as long as it's not
rotationally as long as the the measure
isn't rotationally invariant there will
be a unique solution if I look at enough
data
that's kind of fun that's kind of an
interesting thing to think about you say
what G do I pick well I'm going to pick
this one because I know it's not
rotationally invariant people pick other
ones
how do you pick a measure well you pick
the problem the PDF proportional to
something that looks like a CDF what
does this function look like it's just a
sigmoid function
so I pick the probability distribution
so it's kind of low to high it's not
rotationally invariant on each component
and I'm done
that's kind of wild okay
I'm not super worried that like you
grock absolutely everything here again
these lectures are not supposed to walk
you through line by line and read the
book to you what it's supposed to do is
give you a high level structure for how
this algorithm is going to go and what
are the key twists
now the one thing that's that'll
probably scare you is you're like well I
don't know how to compute the gradient
of the log of a determinant and weirdly
enough that actually has a form
so that is actually a that's an object
that you can compute and compute
gradient descent on and so you just run
gradient descent
on W you have to do some derivatives in
the old days I guess now you don't have
to compute derivatives anymore you have
Auto diff software for you which will
kind of do it automatically like Pi
torch will do this for you or jacks or
something but maybe we make you do it by
hand I don't know if we actually do that
but we do you can do it it's not bad you
look it up or you drive it it's not
super hard
but it is weird that it works
okay and miraculously I'm not going to
have to convince you of this in class
you run the thing and you will hear
someone saying one two three four five
some ta and it will work even though the
what's at the microphones is a mix
pretty wild
all right
all good
oh by the way why so what is the log of
the absolute value of the determinant
right it's the determinant is the
product of all the eigenvalues right so
if you take their absolute value and
take their log it's going to be the
absolute values of the sums of the
eigenvalues now that looks a little
trace-like so you can imagine why this
is actually relatively easy to compute
but your W small you can brute force it
for these kind of things
okay awesome
any questions about this please
this piece right here yeah so what we're
doing is we have P of the speakers each
one of them some probability
distribution I'm being vague at this
point when I was writing it because I
wanted to basically get to the point we
can use any distribution that's the
weird thing basically any distribution
so long as it's not rotationally
invariant so I don't know what PS is yet
but just imagine it now I'm going to
move it to a distribution from SJ to a
distribution on X's so the speakers I
can't observe I don't get to measure
them but I do get to measure the X's now
I only have one variable that controls
everything that's w
now I can do gradient descent on W I
didn't know how to do it on their
product before I'm setting S and W as a
product but because there's only one now
I can run gradient descent on it and it
happens to be kind of nicely concave and
all the rest of the stuff I want
[Music]
exactly right and the thing and the
thingard here that I want you to
confront is and when the assignment is
like if you use the standard
distributions you don't get you don't
get a unique answer and weirdly enough
almost any distribution you use will
work we happen to pick this one but you
could have picked something else and
that's kind of wild
so right that's a weird thing just can't
just have to be able to distinguish it
and what you think about there is the
prior on the speaker doesn't matter too
much
they just can't mix in some awkward way
you can't rotate the speakers
intensities and have it make sense you
have to be able to distinguish kind of
up versus down
fantastic other questions
all right so I'm going to spend please I
want this Jeep yeah like how things
exactly you can get like how do you get
the deal this one is exactly
proportional yeah you don't okay so I
can take any function I want and
normalize it as long as it has like some
very it's smooth and other things and
normalize it from like minus one to one
or minus infinity to Infinity as long as
it's integrable and make it into a
probability distribution as long as it's
positive right positive this function's
positive I want it to go kind of uh I
wanted to go from low to high so it has
that nice feature to it and I don't care
about anything else but now that's a CDF
right because now I have a function
which the integral of which is you know
zero the zero to one and then what I'm
going to do is I'm going to take a
differential and that's what gives me
the PDF
this is just probability Theory stuff
but yeah and you're like the thing that
should bother you and is bothering you
is like why did you pick this function
and then I'm telling you that's
disturbing go pick other functions still
works
but there's one function that if we use
which we've been using the whole quarter
all sudden everything breaks
that's weird it just means that like
not every prior matters sometimes priors
get these like you know undefinability
things and it's coming from this
rotational invariance and that's weird
it's going to bother you but then you
run the code and you're like oh my god
it works and you can play with it see
how close you can make it to rotation
the invariant if you motivate or you
just do the homework and turn it out
either way
but that's what's interesting
right I'm going to lose our last little
bit of time together to tell you
something kind of different which was
sometimes about weak supervision this
would be less mathematical and
potentially have
more bizarre pictures
we didn't get any activity on the thread
I want to tell you about one Trend since
this is our last lecture together
will take over
and we'll see if we get through this
all right okay
so I want to tell you about weak
supervision and I want to just motivate
it for you in the last 20 minutes of why
we care about it and mathematically the
reason we care about it is it's an
example the underlying model that I'll
show you is an example of these em style
models but we can solve it exactly in a
lot of situations these are my slides
and I have to give these quinoa to give
a keynote this morning if you have two
more this week on random conferences
they have lots of weird pictures on them
just ignore them okay
so the mo let me motivate for you why I
care about weak supervision and then I'm
going to skip over some stuff and then
we'll try and get to the mathematics of
the model okay so the reason we started
thinking about weak supervision and
others too this thing we call data
Centric AI was that machine learning at
least in a supervised setting has three
pieces it has a model which you're
learning a lot about in this course it
has training data which we've talked
about a whole bunch it has Hardware
and the thing is which is weird outside
this class and for a variety of good
reasons models have become Commodities
so all of you in this room can go
download you know Google Microsoft
Stanford's latest models just the
culture of AI is that we put everything
online and there's been a ton of
investment in in that so if you want a
state-of-the-art natural language model
you can download it like go to hugging
face download it you want state of the
art Vision model there's a tutorial
somewhere that will allow you to do it
you can get it instantaneously and
because of the cloud Hardware is a big
problem it's not a big problem people
can get access to it okay still
interesting problem but it's there but
training data is hard this was the
original idea and the reason training
date is hard is it's the way that you
encode your problem about the world it's
how you label it now when I tell you
about uh you know supervised machine
learning the first day we have X and Y
Pairs and I never tell you where they
come from
you have X and Y pairs they came from
God herself they landed there and you're
like well this is where machine learning
stars but that's not at all how anything
Works in machine learning it doesn't
start then and it's not like hanging out
with Beyonce it's like living in a sewer
so if you want to do this stuff in
Industry it is much more like hanging
out in a dirty filthy sewer you have all
these data streams you don't know where
the heck they came from they all have
weird errors they all have weird
correlations with one another and it's a
huge mess and so we started to look at
this problem a couple years ago with
many other folks in the field and we
just wanted to put mathematical and
system structure around how to make this
less awful okay that was the motivation
right now I'm not going to bore you with
the fact that like people actually do
this and and all the rest it turns out
that like you know this is an
interesting area but I'm just going to
show you a toy example so
here's a toy example and a little bit of
light math okay so here's an example of
something we may want to do and generate
training data and there's a whole longer
talk here of of how exactly this works
let's say you want to do named entity
recognition you want to label persons
and hospitals in text okay you just want
to know you have some mentions or these
mentions of people or text Saint Francis
could be a person could be the hospital
Bob Jones probably a person but I guess
could be a hospital too okay so here's
how these weak supervision Frameworks
work they basically allow you to have
these little voters that you write to
reuse training data that you had before
an existing classifier that's already
voting person you just throw it in
here's another kind of classification
rule uppercase existing classifier says
person you put that in and then Hospital
well I have a dictionary of Hospital
names it's called distance supervision
so this one votes hospital and the point
is is each one of those noisy sources in
the sewer is telling you something
different and all you want to do is
determine How likely is answer a versus
answer B okay
so this is how it works in a particular
engine this is the first system that did
it there's many others since then don't
worry too much about that but what it
did is it estimated this graphical model
and I'll show you how it works in just
one second because it will look very
familiar to you
you take in all those sources and you
try to estimate how accurate is every
source and how correlated is every
source with one another and then you
make an estimate over all the labels for
every point
how probable How likely is it a person a
hospital or whatever okay that's what
you want to do
so we model this as a generative process
okay there's the graphical model there
you've probably seen something like this
and the instance here is we want to
learn the Y value that's there the label
that's there without any hand label data
so we want to look at the votes and
somehow deduce the why okay there are
reasons you want to do this that are
Beyond this but we're not going to have
any label data when we do it and we want
to learn the correlations and the
accuracies
okay awesome
so it's not at all obvious that you
could do this
the reason it works is because you can
see these voters on many data sources
millions of data points every point that
comes in every voter registers yes no or
indifferent and you can look at their
observe that they're overlapping
judgments and estimate their accuracy
and their correlation if you knew for
example Source One was always right you
just count how often every Source agreed
with Source One and that would tell you
the accuracy of source 2 and Source
three okay but they could be correlated
as we saw that first function and second
function called each other
they could be correlated in some way and
you'll have to deduce that okay
all right
so here's the way that you solve these
underlying problems I'm just going to go
through this very quickly because we
don't have all the math but it basically
looks like those covariance matrices
that we saw from before
the problem here is that we want what's
in the red we want to know how often
does Y which we don't see how often this
thing let's make us make it zero or one
so it's true we don't see how often Y is
correlated with one source we only see
how often the sources are correlated
with one another so set another way we
can only observe what's in Sigma sub o
we don't get to see how often the
sources correlate with the ground truth
okay
now here's the thing that is pretty
interesting it turns out that the
inverse of this Matrix has a structure
this is one of the most beautiful
mathematical facts that comes from the
graphical models course and I'll just
state it here without proof
it turns out that every time this
graphical structure is missing an edge
there's a zero in The covariance Matrix
okay
this allows us to write this in terms of
The observed values and the and some
rank one parameters
and these zi's basically say if they're
one they have perfect accuracy and zero
their total noise
okay
now why that's interesting is it lets us
set up a bunch of these equations
that basically say we know the left hand
side is zero because let's imagine I
know the structure I know how they're
correlated you can solve for that if you
want it
and it turns out this will be kind of
weird stuff it turns out that actually
here you can complete this as long as
you have enough of these linear
constraints
now a couple of things here first Z and
minus Z are solutions so this gives us
back to those symmetry questions I
wanted to highlight you can't tell if
everybody's correlated with the ground
truth or the exact opposite
you have to make an assumption if you
had a bunch of malicious labelers who
were all telling you the exact wrong
thing and correlated each other you
would get fooled
so you have to make some assumption
there
the second thing is when zi is out equal
to point is equal to zero that means
it's a coin flip if I added a labeler
that just flipped a coin this should
give you no information and indeed it
won't it will it will Zero out every
constraint that it's in with sanity
checks you can't kind of make your job
easier by adding these labelers
it turns out it won't bore you there's a
great paper from version from like 2014
2015 that measures the notion of rank in
a continuous way it's called effective
Rank and this tells you the right
statistical scaling for this problem the
closer those Z's get to zero when can
you recover The Matrix super fun stuff
it's a nice geometric piece okay so you
heard all this stuff I just wanted to
share with you it's stuff that I end up
working on you probably think at this
point like there's no way anyone would
ever use these crazy covariance matrices
but I just want to share one thing with
you which is wild to me because my
students did this it's actually used in
all these applications it's still in
production all these years later and
this is a way that people cope with the
fact that they have lots of noisy
training data and put them together so
in search ads in Youtube Gmail and
products from Apple and so this weird
framework of how you program training
data just something I wanted to share
with you and the underlying model is
like classical from what you've seen
except for instead of solving these em
problems you solve these weird
covariance Matrix inverse problems and
you can solve them provably now turns
out to be important for a variety of
weird issues of like estimating Source
quality you don't want to rely on Em
which we talked about doesn't have a
unique answer for this we can tell you
exactly where the unique answer is
thank you for your time and attention
and thank you we'll see you on Wednesday